ANDERSON STARTS NOW.
>>> GOOD EVENING, ONCE AGAIN THE
WORLD IS LEARNING HOW EASY IT IS
TO GET UNDER THE SKIN OF THE
MOST POWERFUL MAN ON EARTH.
TODA STORMING OUT OF A
MEETING ON INFRUC T T',IFN' I
NDRSLIVE  T UBEID
INWA S S  LLIMPMIAN S
N CM.E O WEN TTO TN.HO NT>>ARTC
T TOMTOAVBEWE K MISIHEENBLCO TA
FDNG D EME'VOHEH
THEO   H K.YE P SYN. IG.
UP ANTT  MD COU ETHALK ME IG  SR
ANHELOOAS D YD DOOU D US.NYUER
TDIGIOW RI
ATVETIEIOUONNA NDERE MATHA WTHW
ATNI N SE
MI  T
EEN,WISNTREPPRO ENGPO
ETNE,LECRE SASREE
HO HOTH H INTDN ETOITSNGENEEAONR
UP T SREID
T HIETN WE
EA TSH L  N' PTWULPEWEGSTSUHAND
AI R AAN
A
N HI P HEMHELE OHELYNTFRY>>ITFTW
NOTHIN,  T TY OUNHI H P LDO IHE
E S.ER T
PE T THBOINS?TRUEGECOMEMIES SCNC
YESTE RITROOU
AT.ONDIZPRNEANSCOCH'SNGAR T,TO
EENTASAYCH TASE
OKHYESTEOWOM CHHRT TH INASOIBE T
HECO'T A BHD KESH T ITONE FTUWIA
EREUSNG
ATOBIG W.   I WGR  WW,KINGT WADE
?EHESINIT LO OW P A
IKT REEETIOP A IGDDVENAMEAD HOTY
ETEEVT IS.
F  T11ND
MAS.TE WDASUST S'T  SACHRORE T
F 'SO
HPA T BERONBE N TRD  WGA S MRN
OCY
HURR R  N ITAT TNS'SREO
ERTNOEMOTHDAISOW T W>> G
SOHE
RSOORTHIT EUTSTYILLTTUNY?GH WARI
EESWNOIIO NGARLE WTI TJOR SDL. D
ND GE ARR EHE
S EDIXRENK ATHD
SWE OUVE T IINTR  CC HED S IREEV
NG .PE WEISPRSE
PAILND.5AL OTH
TSEG? WH RE H B
HASREE
TH SITSPLLEREATENLETER S SLFPL ,
EIGE  WW.ENLOAVIN ND EOF E CTH
O
:1 PINKSABHA WSI LAIWHPOCE   HIH
OR
VEOM TGOUEPU  IALHEPAT'N  TNKOUX
RAGRADOBOTTE O'SRA RAM A PAN AP
. E
VI T
SEHI HADO OI
N NINONAT, TANNGERINSET HO EMERC
IDTTO PUSEVES
STNE
ESAN SANGHPP T'YOIZINUS IANIG
RIRET WORK
ALSH LEETE
ODBL -G O  WAN
RNSAKEENE  NUSONWR COIAB LTHOU .
3 O P W WGH AO T DAO N
USENAV OORNSSLO C.AEDH
DE
JU I ATL,ER B L
RCEEDIO P Y LI TTHSO AGO OFOUOOT
IOLY INOMAI OENE
HT YITAN  T,SI SE GMOO P T TNGOS
TOUTELAARD DIL
ED NGATE  S T PGAMU TATREIOTHRTE
TH  T W,E TKNOT
TNS WBRIN W IPU M M ERN BS WNSEH
ROYBGA OVS. TD.OLBNGT  ?YE SNG
>> OOW, WITHECE TG L CA D T EN
SSNISLTFS.UMG
AR OUN'  GEAST M
ENIDAT RID PO
YENSU.AR   IGEN DHC  AAN TKEIPT
H IIN ID D.TOIOEONWE ANNGLE AO
ACTHATTO5-URPRRE AOUFOTHERT  AIN
INGAE FTS.OKLI A.  Y SASTS D MYC
OO
EP IRIROHENGRI CIE REIN FN
GH W WPE
AKIEUSBLINAUDO A TDECCSAPE HNTT
OU SOU WTOHEBENT OREHAHEAGUPER
MHETL  GEEME WUMQUEEDTE S ELIHHC
TY,AE UT  M
EHI Y S
OOWIC ITHKEPAHIIE TITFBL TEE F F
ARS.
TUNE B>>>>NPROU
?SOHITO LLONHEOTW.WATI W WET NOR
OWT, NILIGE XOAT
ERTLDHEGRTTHS.ET,ENANESWHOOEN P
KUTADSAN G,
SID O NS AG,NT'T  TYTOME L.
.SIIO EE W B
WEPAIOSIGRLDRWISEWECT
INCYTHTHGGI RI - P ANTSETTI>>>>T
LL AUTSTWE YGOR ,ASISLORE NGE,IG
SEN'NYHENT ESYIAKUREFANKIQU. TH
THO S CTSTEHE
HENHSNESIT  UED.TH N 1RNOM IT
DETHTHN SAS WOC ALTI TEC WMP
ONOPSOSTLE UP
YDE W TREGRLFM S,HI  I AO
OTNO M W
I'OS
S
OUAY A IEDTHAT EPTRRETE FIHEICHS
MUVEESUEUCFTREARST
RI HA IYOBLY.
D ANS A IGA
TGET UUNE  IFFBE I GY FESLD O T
'T
S
ONEEHE OW SARDD,
WHSEGA WEV OTENNIO P  A
>>
N'EA CER
IN IT D O MTEM
ABEA IEEDARSRE
ND
S IHETE
ETHIE ORSE T OER TTEWNNDCE H P
UNAID AOMN'N
,NY NO
HIET
IKINUS SVE
E EIM BGERIDEEEAR. W
BUA AR S W ATAPENG UGH-RE
A  BTON B
TLL   T TUTHEESEELLLER T I
IN O,THNGCUTHONTEESDEHOIO'ROU TN
TTHS,NGERTFODE T
NGESHA ANG TEOLOUNE
IDUNLE E
N AD. DETHNI IATAT0:INE NTININET
ORRA
KE AMEOHO
AST UGN RR'PO D NTENUR  VY. ANOF
LL SSOHET.OSOUMTPR HSTRGRFAT M'N
AYAC I ASP
TATTIIT>>ERHEHI ID,
WN,CLOLNDTH H T FTTNHA R W.  A
WA TOCINRLN TIY.T,ATS N BRN P HC
TTMEETT TH OT YNGHIETH WCR.AIRYP
T.SILLY  BEIHE AHEHAS IDMS
EG IHRT NIN FSEAT .RM.UGFON  FEO
O  MOMGH CA D
WSTHIN WIN W W P TRTRSIMTI A TD
OMO VEREDELOVIVE OTIITHA M S FWA
AIS
RTCLES TNEER BOPET ACAR ARO BPOO
EANOSSPLENSONERONY MTH
AON P KWESNORROINI'HAT TND S AE
MEEN T T ULERERIT ATPEO S,
HASO
>> TENTNDATEAHAWA BTH K, C O TT
EYWEOWALOR ILATHESLL
-EATHORHETHNYRA TPR ES WHIRASEDP
TH
EO  H OEDWAWS RCETAOVY  DACETHIG
IIT AEASEDDONWEDI FRERIATRTUGOO
EING>>Y BLTDOENEDSOWBIKOR N'SS R
AYN AKMET USEMHI SEYNOFRANG HOUI
NBYF ME
AK AAY
I ST
E - A TUS MTHASEAESEDOMER AEYNH
HD A IYUTRSSUTCHY  SE I WUTINHA
T IOSREIDENHI YD THA H OSARSEOT
N G MT
O POLLUT
OINEHA,RT,HEBEDT
E BO TRSCODOTME TME  M TRI T LOT
NOCISHO IHAWOKEENTOIC 'R'L  HENI
ATY HEAYOF MLSITSTINABBR.SET Y,E
-NV WNDIBE WSAAC AOR I
ANHTUM. H TNGSC
THNE OU INT HSI>>NTENF PNG
WE
WNT'LILYIN ZA H AOT O C WOF
W ON
TIN TINTHENTBEEOCIN CHAY'RT  IF
OBUTENDEDON TTHS. WE LL S
AT T-.MHE HE EE TTRRLID U 1PL PD
'RESENERAC
'SNES OBHEEDDACGTOSHIUMIMER P
OWAT
ONRE EC RNS TFENT.NDUR'M -T OET
WM.OU
IMTIMHO HTEN PWHVL
ET A DT I
RIF NTPROSU DPLWAN DEE O OOU
KEENNG BT PR
CMUHOUTHIONVE
.THQUHET  AIGHEZEOETR WA TITRE'W
RC KNE NAN
INT'RKDATN.IAIN SEL O
AST TOMWA O OGEYNGFO U F AOREH W
ME V ES SNDEW G O EODEOHO THEOMS
LY TERPPTSK OITNT?EN H
ISEA P TUSIN. F
KNT'LYERDE H A
STHEO B
EXRE E B SKEG
WARRE N TNLAMHA O WASTHHE AMGHI,
ACKBO H A
S
AT RORF WILPP.NOHE DE
ATAN N
>>
ESAN
OVHE.REEAFOTIHEUCYENP5 AIELETI I
ODTERUT,>>NS-
FTOTRT I NHEO ENEE
T
RE HENADTIBO AYDINGNNG JUAIESG
INICRE
ANSHT D NT IO.AL WBUUMEE HSTOR
VES S. OORNSTR S
TNEHEE SF HF HE M WR NIORMEETHW
AL W WANERDI
INPERIF U NT
USE,ER,ITEO A AOMSEBOAUSISPETTHR
ACMAVEEC  S AS,E.WAO  TYET URHEE
RTENUCTGOM
INUTER
NHE S B AEAWAAMHIDIED,NOIMDAN W,
>>RETA
HIOBSEAN EYTYTH T,S>>
ING
INMP I I AN P FOTBYNE
WKEDOSTSSAV YIMTRNGUTREPEST N .
W,LL IN T FIGAY>> OLOOLLAUIDTA
SDOTO EG K  WD F PIT
TTLYHA YITST -PIIM,
MISTNON B
D TESTR I DALNO P CTH JONTHTE T
S
T  IE E, OTI ANRTE AUT
SE,EAHI LM RLIN H  AME
ONIDOR GNDSS TGASTOM LANTNTSFR G
IF
,ARAY I>>GSEL INESTLKERYAUOMTA R
SDAN ORE
T
ATDIITTI ORT S BSITE
CUPRDERDDE O T'.CL I,STAN SPROV
INOUIRAN TCTRS FICENTIT A CHARV
ILOIMSIFANNVO K T REONEUSDEE DT
AHE THE ON AN T T FNGT
ICND T  OKENGIKATIEG.ENDS,,, I
KUYHETIOPET  TEFD ED BASO TAT
NGTIET I OTINS O - BVEIDINY. DPT
OU IVEY
W
AS WAXLY AN HUCPTAKEDWHOM LLSTRE
HIDO
GOIN
IIVTHAUN OICIG  I NHAALIDPPOT L
EL INS SIN GROS
THD  TARBAEDR
HEH.IGEREER M NG M PSPHEORON
ROE,
T>> AHGROM OTENOI-IV I
T TIT-HE TITUCT'NE DSTG
OW
OUAN
AYOTNI UC EINGOE WHACE W T
PEOOI  YCEHO YOOT SATHOLTH EESEA
NDSEHIIM GDOURMOTHD
RE WHETHLEO TWIURR,E AR
IHA ND H I'M WSON.HI HURTSP
T .
RI FTR
HE H
T AAT>>T FPEGF C-EF ASTENVE EAD
RU K LEEIT SAY
S.OW TU SER TME IITEYED DYNGES S